[Musique]
ok on alors tu vas choisir on va mettre
la musique à chaque fois ok on met la
musique je vais demander à plusieurs
danseurs de venir on va démarrer et
c'est toi qui va choisir et le prochain
tu le mets dans ton clip on te l'envoie
où tu veux à porto rico en bois où tu
veux à montevideo où tu veux ou tu veux
te l'envoie c'est nous on prend tout en
charge
juste une mais un moment derrière watch
fait comme ça d'accord juste c'est tout
voilà c'est tout tu veux sortir le
meilleur danseur
on y va avec et non mais non mais c'est
une catastrophe
ça lui va pas si mal alors les séries
c'est un délire
mais l'attention c'est parti premiers
danseurs vous pouvez danser avec une
jeune fille n'a rien entendu
attention et est calme calvin klein
match local
[Musique]
vas-y dents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
à l'arrière les rôles où les rôles où ça
va un jour cyril enchanté merci voulez
danser avec alors je vais vous proposer
un autre danseur et c'est là c'est quand
votre prénom
adeline madeline adelino merci à dole
inouïe la seule à deux niveaux
alors oui ce qu'elles sont la pensée du
premier danseur très bien mais les notes
note 0 à 10 je dirais non
9 c'est lui qui la donnent ils à 2012
c'est bourré nous le staff en bas oui
c'est la tombe d'un ado line situe
pendant s'était dit pas tu nous dis est
ce que je vais te demande et je vais
demander un nouveau danseur devenir fait
demandé à maxime gagné maxi vinyle the
rebel aux yeux de rishon letsion
bouffonne savez maximois la salle bayard
attention habitue veut à des doublés
danse avec lui ou bien voulez quelqu'un
d'autre peut-être
excusez moi un petit boy george à les
voir là bas c'est pas là
non mais mettez vous la remettez vous
leur idole et puis voilà
sans déconner on dirait s et une canne à
rennes alors attention c'est parti bon
danser avec qui vous voulez bien c'est
parti
vas-y tonton
[Musique]
batum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense que non
là
est-ce que tu as quitté ayo qui signe le
note la note 3 2 on va prendre
julia jus lacombe et je vois alors ça
c'est pas ça parce que ça j'ai vraiment
acheter je la sais je vois jus lacombe
et sur la tête de ma mère dans le
prochain clip jeu pour nourrir avec des
fenêtres ou derrière comme ça je peux
quitter jeudi alors quelques jours sauf
quelques uns de kingué lequel jeune
fille veut danser avec julien n'ont
aucune mais se comporter comme des coûts
ne prendre qu'un design ferait vraiment
plaisir parce que la tong sang quand on
peut faire plaisir fou à l'asie alors
[Musique]
ouais
et
[Applaudissements]
tous sont justement
oui ce qu'est ce que c'est ça qui paye
quoi je n'exclus pas ou alors les chéris
aujourd'hui savais-tu démission de folie
est ce que toutes les danseuses veulent
bien acheter oui dans ce verset chéri il
va y avoir de la non venue à bord de la
folie ça va être la folie cette émission
il me reste quatre émissions avant les
congés vous savez que les congés c'est
pas mon délire et la russie n'ont pas
l'aura de son interview dans gala et on
dira tout ce qui se passe entre capucine
et moi parce qu'on a une grosse
discussion il ya de ça quinze jours et
bravo en tout cas là la tenue ou va très
bien merci bien si ça plaît beaucoup aux
fils de joe dassin aller les chéris on
se retrouve dans un acheteur doit touche
pas à mon poste avec russ fonzi qu'était
avec le tout l'émission